for 16 years we've been asking you about
a friend's rebooting now you said maybe
and now I know and now you did this to
us
you did this well you know no was
getting me nowhere maybe was getting me
nowhere so I don't know I thought I'd
try yes see what happened
[Music]
anything can happen I have no idea
though there's no plans in them in the
immediate future
so everyone calm down yeah or keep or
don't and don't stay excited and
possibly something will happen do you
notice anything out of the ordinary
what we didn't do this someone's trying
to frame us we do things together so can
we please just figure this out what did
Adam at what did Adam have to do to
convince you to do this movie asked me
that was it that's a no-brainer for me
he says yes he says please and you say
yes you just say where how much fun did
you guys have traveling through Europe
hanging out in all these iconic
locations - I know it was pretty fun it
was not a shabby job we kind of kept
pinching I remember every morning
driving up to work and seeing some crazy
ancient location and just thinking is
this real life this is where I get to go
to work today
[Music]